mais notre seul avenir y est quand même
ailleurs lle dans l'emploi parfois non
pas du seul but des récoltes mais dans
l'emploi comprend des grands noms de
richesses industrielles qui sont les
grandes richesses primaire d'un peuple
d'un territoire comme le nom la forêt
l'eau les mines et ça c'est des choses
qu'on contrôle l'emploi qu'on apprend on
nous voit un avenir où ben ouvre une
espèce de croupissement médiocrité comme
des spectateurs qui regardent ce qui se
passe chez eux mais qu'ils y
participeront
et ça ça appartient ça appartient pas
complètement suffit de décider
raisonnablement on pas y avoir pensé
mais décider que c'est nous qui décidons
justement mais toutes façons concept de
fabriquer des littéralement des épaves
prédestiné a été pendant toute leur vie
c'est possible du apple fait sur ces
servir de ce qu'on a
concept aussi des spectateurs de ce qui
se passe chez nos points de vue
économique
pis ce qui se passe chez nos points de
vue économique nos produits techniques
si on n'y est pas si on participe pas
puis au besoin il va participer c'est
pas la fin du monde tous les étals forme
fédérale le faire c'est notre pays
participer avec l'état sur la peau les
moyens autrement puis je comprenais les
moyens souvent autrement